we're doing sunscreen reviews!
yay!
it's Michelle of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry PhD
cosmetic chemist and sunscreen connoisseur
today I'm talking about a bunch of
international sunscreens I've tried recently
all of these are quite popular on social media
there's two from haruharu this video's sponsor
the rest are sunscreens that I picked up when I
was in the US a little while back for open sauce
I've been dying to try out some of these for years
and I know that a lot of us sunscreen nerds
are not really that into US sunscreens
but honestly it didn't go that badly
not as badly as I expected anyway
I'm going to start with the haruharu wonder
black rice moisture airfit daily sunscreen
this is a Korean chemical sunscreen
with a different formula from a lot
of the ones that are really popular at the moment
I think most people have heard about
this like family of Korean chemical
sunscreens that are sort of
like variations on a theme
they use this blend of filters
they each have slightly different skincare
ingredients and textures and they are some
of my favorite sunscreens of all time
but some people have told me that
they don't really like these formulas
they can have white cast on darker skin
probably because of that mbbt filter
it is a chemical or organic sunscreen but it is
in particles so it scatters more visible light
some people don't like the texture and
some people just find them kind of boring
so this haruharu sunscreen is an
alternative chemical sunscreen
formula which uses these different filters
and you will notice there is no mbbt there
so this one has zero white cast
on me and I've seen reviews from
people with darker skin saying it
has no white cast on them as well
it's also made by Kolmar which is the big Korean
sunscreen manufacturer that makes a lot
of the really popular Korean sunscreens
I'd say this is on the more moisturizing and
creamy end of Korean chemical sunscreens but
it is still really lightweight with
a creme gel moisturizer consistency
it applies really smoothly
and feels hydrating without
being greasy and it leaves a slightly
tacky moisturized feeling on your skin
I think a lot of people underestimate
the importance of the inactives in
a product when it comes to the texture
and the overall experience of sunscreen
so I'm going to talk a little bit more
about them and this is actually like
one of the few times I think reading the
ingredients list can be kind of helpful
to get the cream gel consistency which is
popular in so many Asian skincare products
not just with sunscreens but
also with like moisturizers
formulas usually use a polymeric emulsifier
that means it will hold the oily and watery
parts of a product together without needing
as much of those traditional emulsifiers
which can feel a bit thick and heavy
closer to the top of the ingredients list
for this is polyglyceryl-3 distearate
this goes on a little bit shiny but it sinks in
pretty quickly and it glides on just so smoothly
there's no fragrance and it doesn't pill on
me and it sits really nicely under my makeup
in terms of other skincare actives this
has ceramides as well as niacinamide and
adenosine and that's what makes this
a triple functional cosmetic in Korea
in other words as well as being an SPF
is also brightening and anti-wrinkle
Haruharu also has this other sunscreen which is
the black rice pure mineral relief daily sunscreen
this is another fragrance free sunscreen and it
mostly uses zinc oxide as well as an SPF booster
this goes on with a bit of white cast
which is what you expect from a zinc
oxide sunscreen but it dries down
to only a tiny amount of white cast
it is as good as I've tried with
any untinted zinc oxide sunscreen
the finish is not very greasy it's more of
like a hydrated finish and it is slightly
slide-y so you can blend out any white streaks
pretty easily after it's mostly dried down
again this has a cream gel consistency
and it uses a polymeric emulsifier
this one is a little bit worse
just in terms of like reading it
it's polyglyceryl-3
polydimethylsiloxyethyl dimethicone
I personally tend not to prefer mineral sunscreens
but this is one of my favorite formulas so far
again it's from Kolmar and I just feel
like they really know how to make good
sunscreens that people enjoy using
it's also got niacinamide hyaluronic
acid and I think that's what contributes to
this being not too drying and not too greasy
it is just hydrating which is pretty
rare with mineral sunscreens on my skin
I always love a good pump
container with my sunscreens
I find them really nice and easy
to dispense and you can easily
work out how many pumps you need to use
I personally have this problem and maybe you
do too I kind of accidentally just start using
less and less sunscreen over time and I don't
necessarily notice and every once in a while I'll
have to recalibrate how much sunscreen I'm using
so pumps are really good for that
because then you can just say
I will always put on X number of pumps which I've
measured out once and never have to measure again
for my face these ones I would need three pumps
and it would be three to six pumps probably for
most people depending on the size of your face
and it also depends on how much of your hands
you use to apply because that will also count
as extra surface area and it can be quite a lot
both of these are available from the official
Amazon page and the links are in the description
I picked up a whole bunch of popular US
sunscreens to try and this is really not
meant to be like a comparison video
because it would be pretty unfair to
compare US sunscreens with Korean sunscreens
they have different filters and very different
regulations so really this is like a
good opportunity for me to get a bunch
of sunscreen reviews out there because I have
a bunch piled up that I just haven't released
first we have the Supergoop Unseen sunscreen
this is a really popular US sunscreen
I got a little variety pack from
Sephora which actually has really nice
kits and really nice like gift sets
it's so much nicer than Australia
my Australian phone number actually
worked in their loyalty card system
which was pretty cool and I got like
a little birthday gift which was nice
I don't know I feel like we don't
have things like that in Australia
anyway this is SPF 40 it's PA with three
pluses and it is water resistant for 40
minutes which is quite unusual for a
face sunscreen so I quite like that
this is a chemical sunscreen and the
filters are I'm gonna put them up here
the formula is really interesting it is
a water-free silicone-based formula and
when you squeeze it out it is completely clear
this sort of formula is usually used in pore
filling makeup primers and honestly I don't really
like these formulas I find them really hard to
apply or rather they're kind of too easy to apply
so they glide on really nicely but I
can't get the full amount onto my face
so for my sunscreen reviews I always weigh
out the right amount of sunscreen for my face each
time just so that everything is equal and fair
with these sorts of formulas it kind of feels like
I'm spreading icing on my face and it feels like
it's sitting on my skin in a really thick layer
sort of like I'm slugging and it's not sinking
in and I'm just like moving it around endlessly
it does sink in a bit these formulas use a lot of
isododecane as the solvent which is volatile and
so that evaporates as the sunscreen dries down
as you're applying it there is like this sort of
solventy smell but that goes away pretty quickly
one thing I do really appreciate
about these silicone formulas
is how matte they are when you put them on
they can get shiny after a few hours if you're
quite oily but they are pretty impressive with the
mattifying effect but on my skin at least it kind
of feels like it just doesn't ever set properly
it feels like I have this film on my skin even
though it does look matte it just
sort of feels greasier than it looks
I also feel like some of it comes off on
my fingers when I brush against it even
hours later but if you have dry skin these
do tend to do better and they have a really
nice smoothing sort of makeup priming effect
so yeah I can see why this is so popular I
think a lot of people would love this sort
of formula but it's just not really for me
next we have the Trader
Joe's daily facial sunscreen
this is very clearly designed to
be a dupe of the Unseen sunscreen
it has a really similar ingredient list
it really annoys me when people say two
products are dupes when they're designed
completely differently with like different
classes of ingredients and the only thing
they have in common is literally they are
both sunscreens or they are both micellar waters
but this and the Unseen sunscreen are actually
functional dupes they have the
same SPF they have the same water
resistance they are both broad spectrum
they do have slightly different active
concentrations although they are the same actives
so there is a little bit of a difference but the
biggest difference is the the price
this is nine dollars for 50 mL versus
I mean this is a tiny one but if
this was 50 mL it would be $38
so like the Unseen this has that clear formula
it's silicone it is water free
it starts off with a slightly stronger
solvent smell that goes away again
pretty quickly after you start rubbing it in
when you squeeze this out it has a slightly
less smooth texture than the Unseen and it
feels a little bit thicker and heavier on my
skin but honestly the difference is not that big
so this is definitely worth a try if you think
this sort of formula might work for your skin
it is really popular it works well for some people
I just prefer products that are a bit lighter
on the silicones and they're more of that cream
gel moisturizer feeling rather than like a primer
with these two sunscreens I personally didn't have
any eye sting but I know some other people have
I am really curious if anyone has tried these
two before and seen any difference
because yeah I did not see one
next we have the supergoop glow screen
this came in the pack with the
Unseen and the shade I got is sunrise
I've seen some people say that
this is the glowy version of unseen
I don't know exactly what they meant by
that but this is a really different formula
this has a creme gel formula but it feels very
different on the skin compared to those other
cream gel sunscreens I've talked about today
and that's because it has a lot of makeup
style pigment and effect particles in it
and that's all the bismuth oxychloride
mica titanium dioxide and iron oxides
that are listed in the ingredients list
I actually prefer the texture of this during
application more than with the Unseen it is a
lot easier to get that full amount onto my
face but after it dries down it does feel
very noticeable on my skin probably because
of all those shimmer particles and the stuff
keeping the shimmer spread out
and we need to talk about the
shimmer because it is just too much
if you use like a sunscreen amount
when you use enough to get that full SPF
40 protection it looks properly metallic
if you apply it a really tiny bit so a primer
amount then it gives you a really beautiful glow
but yeah not with the full amount and there's
also this tint which dried kind of orange
and again I don't think this is an issue if
you use a lot less but sunscreen amounts - no
maybe it might work if you just happen
to be that exact shade but I think this
product is just better suited for people
who are looking for a primer with some SPF
protection and a glow rather than a sunscreen
so yeah I wouldn't consider this a sunscreen
really I would call this a primer with SPF
I am really curious to know if anyone does
like the glow screen when they're
applying the right amount I feel
like a lot of people just aren't applying
enough but yeah let me know in the comments
next we have the blue lizard
sensitive mineral sunscreen
I had to buy this when I was in the US as like
a souvenir because it's "Australian
sunscreen" but it is not Australian
apparently it did originate in Australia
but you cannot buy this in Australia
it's not on the Australian register of sunscreens
and that blue lizard is not an Australian species
Pro tip if something is blue in Australia it
is probably tiny and surprisingly dangerous
and you should get the hell away from it
as an Australian the branding is just a
bit weird but it is really interesting to
see what Americans think of Australians
this is meant to be one of the nicer mineral
sunscreens that you can get in stores in the US
it's got 80 minutes water resistance which
is nice that's the highest you can get there
the ingredients which kind of worried me a
bit was titanium dioxide eight percent and
zinc oxide 10% and no SPF boosters that I can see
so this should be a very safe option for people
who have a lot of chemical
sunscreen allergies but yeah
the fear for me is really just white cast
so during application this gave me a ton
of white cast but it did settle
down surprisingly well after a bit
it does end up greasy and there were like
little white flecks on my skin but overall
I was really impressed by how well this went for
an untinted mineral sunscreen with no boosters
it also has this cap which is pretty
cool it changes color in UV which is
kind of fun if you go into the sun
my partner did use this on a beach
day and he absolutely literally hated it
it just ruined his day because it doesn't
spread well and it was white and
it kind of just drags on your skin
it takes a lot of effort to spread but this is a
good thing for face sunscreens because it means
you don't have that problem with the whole sliding
icing thing on your face when you're applying it
the final greasiness was quite a lot on my
skin and although I was impressed by the
lack of white cast or relative lack of white
cast I wouldn't wear this again by choice
it's just not good for my skin
it might be better if your skin is dry and
again it is one of the few options for people out
there where you don't have any SPF boosters at all
but I have talked to a few people who have a
lot of chemical sunscreen allergies and they
told me that Asian chemical sunscreens
actually work pretty well for their skin
so I think that's also worth considering
if you haven't gone down that road before
blue lizard also have a sheer lotion
which is designed for the face
it's a bit more expensive but it
has less of those active ingredients
they were out of stock when I looked for
it but that might be a bit of a promising
option hopefully it is a bit more wearable
this was a little bit bit annoying to remove
because it is water resistant and greasy but it
wasn't too bad when I used a cleansing oil first
next we have the Australian
Gold Botanical 50 tinted face
this is the fair to light BB cream
again this is not an Australian
sunscreen it is not sold in Australia
the brand actually originated in Florida
I think on the front here these are meant
to be gum leaves which are Australian but
the leaves are like not quite right
they're like not quite the right
shape and actual gum leaves don't have
these like bold sideways branching veins
lab muffin beauty science australiana connoisseur
this is SPF 50 broad spectrum it's also 80 minutes
water resistant and it's got
zinc oxide and titanium dioxide
there are I think three shades available and
this was a pretty good color match for my skin
I would imagine that you would have to have a
pretty good shade match for a product like this
the color did dry down slightly
darker and a little bit more orange
than when I was applying it so test it out
carefully on your skin before you commit
it has eucalypt extract and and it does
smell and feel a little bit minty on the skin
the main thing that stood out to me with this was
how matte it dried it actually blew my mind a bit
it's like the opposite
experience to the blue lizard
that tint once it dried down just did not budge so
if you have it a bit streaky then that's not great
it is very much like a foundation
or like maybe even paint so make
sure you spread it out really well
it is a bit more drying than I like
and it feels a bit like I have a clay mask
on but it is also less drying than I expected
for that level of matte and non-shiny and feel
I was expecting it to really like give me fine
lines and maybe crack a little bit and maybe go a
bit powdery but no it was just like really matte
after a few hours I did see a little bit of oil
breakthrough around my forehead and my nose but
it was just really impressive how matte it stayed
I don't think I've ever had that even with makeup
I can imagine that some people are really after
this sort of finish so yeah I am actually really
impressed with this I haven't had a chance to
try out on a really hot and sweaty day yet so
I'm curious to see how it holds up and what it
looks like after there is a ton of oil and sweat
and I think this goes without saying
but do not use this if you have dry skin
I really don't think will work well for you
maybe you can layer moisturizer underneath and
make it workable but yeah it is matte
have I said that enough
it is matte
getting this
off my skin was surprisingly not that bad I just
used a cleansing oil the skin1004 one and a gel
cleanser and that just completely got rid of it
I've talked a little bit about US filters today
so if you want to find out more about
whether or not they're safe (they are
safe) I have a video about that here
you can also check out my latest list
of top sunscreens and those are
both linked In the description